لقد أضاف موقع Twitter للتحقق من صحة
الرئيس لأول مرة ، أن Twitter هذه الليلة
لم يحدث أبدًا
قبل التحقق من صحة الروابط
لتغريدات الرئيس ترامب حول البريد والتصويت ، حيث
يمكنك أن ترى Twitter يحث المستخدمين الآن
على الحصول على حقائق حول البريد الوارد.  الاقتراع
لأن ما نشره الرئيس على تويتر
لم يكن صحيحًا ، يؤدي النقر على هذا الرابط
إلى نقل المستخدمين إلى صفحة تتضمن قسمًا
ما تحتاج إلى معرفته وتتبع هذه الخطوة
مزاعم ترامب الكاذبة اليوم بأن
بطاقات الاقتراع عبر البريد في كاليفورنيا
سيتم اقتباسها مزورة إلى حد كبير
وينتج عن ذلك اقتباس مزور في الانتخابات
الليلة ، رد ترامب على Twitter
بالطبع ، فإن كتابة Twitter
يخنق حرية التعبير تمامًا وأنا كرئيس
لن أسمح بحدوث ذلك ،
ينضم إليّ برايان ستيلتر الآن ، لذا أريد التحدث
عن ذلك في ثانية واحدة ولكن أولاً
أهمية هذه الخطوة تعرض موقع Twitter
لضغط كبير للقيام بذلك ،
فليس من السهل القيام بذلك ، إنه منحدر زلق
ما دفعه الآن إلى أنه
خطوة  نظرًا لكون تويتر عبارة عن
غرفة أخبار تتصرف كمحرر
وبمجرد أن يتخذوا هذا الإجراء بمجرد
أن يتعرضوا للضغط لفعل ذلك مرارًا
وتكرارًا لأن الرئيس
ينشر مئات الأشياء غير الصحيحة أو
المضللة أو الخطيرة على المنصة
Twitter  حتى الآن لم يتخذوا أي
إجراء ، لذلك من المهم أنهم
يتخذون إجراءً ، لكن هذا يشبه
البصق في غودزيلا أو البصق
في المحيط الموافقة المسبقة عن علم ، أيًا كانت الاستعارة التي فزت بها ،
فهذا إجراء بسيط جدًا تجاه
مشكلة كبيرة جدًا وهي حرب  على
الحقيقة التي تستمر كل يوم بلا هوادة
ليس فقط من قبل الرئيس ترامب ولكن من قبل العديد من
الآخرين الذين يستخدمون منصات وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ، لذلك
من الملاحظ أن تويتر يتخذ إجراءات
ولكن الكثير من الناس لا يقولون
القليل بعد فوات الأوان أو القليل جدًا على الإطلاق
والآن الرئيس يقاتل  مرة أخرى
قائلاً إنه لن يسمح
بحدوث ذلك ، فما أعنيه
أنه يرحب بهذه المعركة التي
يرحب بها هو أن الحملة ترحب
بهذه المعركة التي يريدونها في عام 2020  mpaign
ليكون جزءًا مما يقولون إنه
رقابة محافظة بمعنى
الرقابة على المحافظين من قبل
التكنولوجيا الكبيرة ووسائل الإعلام الكبيرة ، وهي رواية
يتبنونها لأنها تعني أننا لا
نتحدث عن عدد القتلى
وعدد المرضى من Kovan 19 هم
سوف تتبنى هذه الأنواع من
المعارك ولكن انظر إلى ما حدث اليوم
مع ترامب وجو سكاربورو
يضاعف ترامب هذه الكذبة حول جو
سكاربورو الذي يشير إلى أن سكاربورو
مذنب بارتكاب جريمة قتل في مواجهة كل
الأدلة وفي مواجهة أرمل
من يقول أرجوك توقف عن الحديث عن
موتي بالطريقة التي تتحدث بها عنها ، إنه
أمر مخجل ولكن تويتر لن
يتحقق من ذلك ولن يتحقق
فيسبوك بالمثل في هذه
المواقف ، ما اعتاد على إدارة هذه
الأشياء هو آرون  من العار واللياقة
أنك تعلم أن
زملائك السياسيين يخضعون للمراقبة من قبل زملائك من قبل وسائل الإعلام الإخبارية ،
لكن يبدو أنه عندما يكون
شخص ما وقحًا وليس لديه
حشمة  لا يوجد أي من تلك الفحوصات العادية في
نهاية المطاف ، ما الذي سيعالج هذه الحرب
على الحقيقة هم أناس طيبون من جميع
الأطياف السياسية يقولون توقفوا عن الكذب توقفوا عن
اختلاق الأمور بشأن تزوير الناخبين ، توقفوا عن
إيذاء الموتى الأبرياء ، لكن في الوقت
الحالي ، لا يوجد ضغط كافٍ لإيقافها آرون